Yeah,
the basic level it has to do with how
cells can divide many times.
Um,
what was known,
uh,
in the late 19 seventies was that,
um,
that when you copy a chromosome,
the way that the,
uh,
mechanism copies of chromosome,
every time a cell divides the very,
very end bit can't be completely copied.
Uh,
and so then the idea was that the,
uh,
the chromosomes are the telomeres,
which are,
the chromosome ends would get shorter
and shorter and shorter every time a
cell divides.
And that can't happen a indefinitely.
There has to be some mechanism which
will balance that shortening.
And that's where the discovery of
telomerase a comes in.
And so for any cell that has to divide
many times,
they need to have a way to balance so
that there's some shortening and some
lengthening and shortening and some
lengthening and the equilibrium is
maintained,
uh,
so that the cells can then go on and
divide.
We were very interested in,
uh,
as I said,
telomeres and chromosomes and,
and how they,
um,
how they functioned.
And so we really went to the source
where there are a lot of telomeres.
Uh,
and this was something that Liz
Blackburn had done a number of years
before when she had discovered the DNA
sequence that telomeres is made up of,
and it's a very,
very simple repeated dna sequence,
uh,
that is sort of a monotonous many,
many,
many repeats.
And she had discovered the telomere DNA
sequence in this organism called
Tetrahymena.
It's a single celled organism,
very much like the paramecium that high
school students might go out to a pond
and bring back some pond water and see
the paramecium floating around.
The thing about Tetrahymena is that they
have 40,000
chromosomes.
And so it was a very good source to be
able to understand what the ends of the
chromosomes were.
So when we set out to ask,
uh,
is there an enzyme that can lengthen the
chromosomes to balance the shortening?
We went again to Tetrahymena,
um,
and you can just get these organisms and
grow them up in the laboratory.
So we grow up a large batch of the,
of the cells.
And then you spin the cells down in a
centrifuge.
So you make a very compact,
a collection of them.
And then break them open to get the
insides of the cells out so that you can
understand what is going on inside the
cells.
I think it's more that the discovery was
made,
uh,
in 1984 and uh,
it was clear that it was important at
the time,
but it was important as a very basic
cellular mechanism.
Um,
and uh,
there wasn't a lot of questions.
I didn't get a lot of people doubting
what the conclusion was,
but instead it wasn't clear what the
implications were.
And the 25 years that have intervened,
intervened,
uh,
my lab and Liz is lab and a number of
other labs throughout the world have
contributed all kinds of different ideas
from different avenues that have made it
very clear now what the medical
implications are.
And so there are,
are clear medical implications that we
didn't know at all.
At the beginning.
We were just solving a puzzle because we
were curious about how cells worked.
Although we knew that it was a
fundamental mechanism,
we weren't just doing experiments just
to find out anything but rather to
really understand how a cell works.
And the 25 years in between really has,
um,
allowed it to be clear what the
implications of that discovery work.